oh yeah pam it's harriet the respiratory
nurse
pam suffered a stroke on boxing day
very soon afterwards both she and her
husband ron became infected with
coronavirus
they traveled to hospital in the same
ambulance
they lay next to each other in the same
ward eventually
she came home he never did he's lovely
all told i knew him 65 years
he's brilliant he was a brilliant dad
everything
how important is it that someone like
harriet comes to see oh brilliant
i can ring if i want to i've got their
number if i've got a problem i'll just
ring them
what's your oxygen levels been over the
last week or so being too
good pam has copd it's a chronic
lung condition and she needed oxygen
sport
before covid for her
harriet is more than a community nurse
she's
friend physician therapist and much more
and the pandemic means there are many
more patients like pam
who need harriet i think we've even seen
an increase in referrals into our
service over the past few months
and year and i think actually we've got
to look at ways of managing that
community sites are really good actually
looking after patients and managing
their expectations
but i think long term the service is
going to have to grow you know to be
able to cope with the demand
that lengthening list includes covet
patients with the respiratory
complications
and long-term health conditions
referrals in harriet's patch in bexley
southeast london
covered by oxley's nhs trust are already
up
10 on the previous year
for harriet's colleagues the health
crisis has moved
from the hospital to the community
pandemic is not over for us in the
community
actually it's just begun for us in the
community because we're picking up on a
lot of
issues that patients have we already
have people waiting to be seen
but on top of that um we are now dealing
with a population of people who've
become unwell at home and we're trying
to keep them well and stop them going
into hospital
and we're also having to deal with
really complex cases coming out
what this means for us is that we now
have
a caseload of patients who should be on
impatient wards
but actually they're out in the
community i've seen a
massive increase in my referral rate for
people that have had coved
the treatment pathway with high-dose
dexamethasone steroids
is inducing diabetes in some people
the link between steroids and diabetes
is already well known um but it has
it's even it's taken us by surprise the
sheer volume
community nurses like harriet's have
always provided a lifeline for patients
like len right i can just pop this one
on your finger if that's okay
an often unseen workforce delivering
care behind
closed doors it's a role in a
post-pandemic world
that will be more essential than ever
before
ashish joshi sky news in southeast
london